Now, we're looking at the options for handling our online orders.
They're going through the roof. And frankly, the lead time for delivery is blowing out.
We need to improve our performance in this area.
Any suggestions?
Well, as I see it, we have three options.
The obvious one is to employ more people to do the job.
Another alternative is to automate the system more...
...cut down on the physical handling.
And the third option?
We could outsource.
What are the pros and cons?
Well, looking at increasing staff versus automation, we have to consider the cost.
Automating has a higher capital cost than putting on more staff.
On the other hand, employing more people is more expensive over a long term.
If we keep growing, it'll cost more in the long run.
How likely is it that we'll see continued growth?
I'd say it's a certainty.
I'd say a high probability.
Nothing's certain in business.
So, what about the third option?
Outsourcing?
It does take the problem off our hands.
But, we lose contact with our customers.
What about the bottom line?
Outsourcing is the cheapest option, and the easiest in the short term.
But, if we want to keep the operation in-house,...
...the best option is automating our system.
The only downside is, we're taking a risk that our business will keep growing.
Which we hope it will.
We certainly do.